-Guys, we have exactly
seven shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for
"12 Days of Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ 12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ 7 days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show between
now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
an iconic Christmas sweater
from the "Countdown
to Christmas" cabinet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm not saying
it's worth $40,000,
but it's pretty awesome.
Since there
are seven shows left,
let's open door number 7.
You ready for this, pal?
-I'm ready.
-Let's do it.
[ Drum roll ]
Oh, no, wow!
-Oh!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause,
audience groans ]
[ Band plays off-key ]
[ Audience groans ]
♪♪
Uh, wow.
That's beautiful, that one.
Uh...
[ Laughter ]
Is there something on the back?
-Oh, yeah.
-Oh, another one.
Another little
scary something --
[ Cheers and applause ]
At least he's happy.
All right, at least he's happy.
[ Applause ]
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
[ Laughter ]
You have to take the sweater
if you get it.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone, look at
your seat number, please.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drum roll,
please?
[ Drum roll ]
Here we go.
Seat number 126.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go!
Come on down!
♪♪
Hi! Welcome!
Thank you very much
for being here.
Seat number 126.
What is your name?
-I'm Ali.
-Ali, where are you from?
-I'm from Virginia,
but I live in New York now.
-Oh, you're in New York
right now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, today --
today, especially,
it got really cold out.
I thought it felt very wintry.
You don't have anything
like that at home, do you?
-No.
This is my first one of these.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
Here's the good news --
it goes with everything.
-Oh, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Would you like to try it on?
-I would love to try it on.
-Yeah, I'm sure.
Roots, can we just --
I think it'll be perfect.
Yeah, you throw it on your --
-Are you good?
-Yeah.
There's no wrong way to wear it.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not sure
if there's a right way, either.
-This is good.
-Oh, I can --
I can already feel
this is gonna work out.
Wait.
You make it look -- hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You make it look pretty good.
Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about, Ali!
You make it look great, buddy!
I love it!
-Thank you!
-Congratulations once again
to our winner.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Stick around.
We're playing "True Confessions"
with Miley Cyrus
and Pete Davidson
after the break.
Come on back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪